there was an ownership meeting today
another virtual meeting they do won
every quarter december's meeting had
several topics the most important of
which from my perspective whether or not
they're going to expand the regular
season from 16 games to 17. now we all
viewed it as a no-brainer because
the league specifically negotiated with
the union and achieved the ability to
expand the regular season as soon as
next year they've wanted to expand the
regular season for years so why wouldn't
they expand the regular season now that
they have the opportunity to do so all
that said
commissioner roger goodell said on a
conference call within the past hour or
so that the owners did not take a vote
today on expanding the regular season
but they did vote
on the scheduling formula that will
apply if they ever do vote to expand the
regular season and shireen here's the
best way i can make sense of this and
this repeats something from pft live but
it also has another wrinkle to it as
well
argument number one
i think it helps the players buy in
if the players want it and as the
players recognize that this is a way to
help repair the damage financially from
the pandemic they may warm up to the
idea of it and say we want this because
we want the salary cap to be higher we
want more money to flow in next year and
this is a way to do it you play an extra
regular season game it gives the nfl 16
more total games 256 goes to 272 before
we get to the post season the other
argument is this and it was sparked by
something goodell said during the
conference call sharing
the idea that they're currently
negotiating with the various networks
the next wave of broadcast contracts you
have to negotiate what people are going
to pay for these extra games so i think
it's all part of that same big bundle of
money flowing to the nfl and if you're
already negotiating extensions why not
negotiate
what will be paid for these extra games
so for those two reasons i think that's
why the nfl is being a little bit coy
i'd be stunned though if we don't have
17 regular season games per team next
year
yeah mike you and i both were on the
call and first of all i'm glad you did
the math on that because i don't know if
i could it could have done it that
quickly um so i'm not sure the math is
right i'm not sure it's right not much
just act like it's right just act like
it's right and hope no one double checks
your work yeah all right exactly that's
exactly right but mike i am wondering do
you think they're waiting to see what
the crowd size might be next year how
covet is going to play out how the
vaccine is going to play out does that
play
any part you think in this i mean tv
makes perfect sense but how much does it
play out with the vaccine and covet and
and how the games are going to look next
season
i think you're absolutely right it's
part of the broader analysis of how are
we going to repair what happened this
year financially with
very few fans in the grand scheme of
things attending these games and there's
been a thought that the salary cap
definitely will drop to 175 million per
team that was the negotiated floor it
won't be any lower than that next year
no matter how much money the nfl loses
but there's a thought
now that the vaccine is being
distributed
and given where things may go over the
course of the next few months they may
be able to project by february or march
hey we'll have full stadiums come 2021.
that's a different analysis to how much
money you're going to make next year to
offset the losses from this year and
then it's it's it's i just think time
benefits the nfl in a variety of ways
what will the money be next year per
game when you factor in attendance
what will the salary cap be and how can
they best negotiate that with the union
and can they make the union want that
17th game so you don't have players
complaining all year long like they
still do from time to time about
thursday night football the more the
players buy in the better it is for
everyone and then you throw on top of it
the looming broadcast negotiation
and i think it makes sense across the
board to wait because there's other rise
no reason and when it first came up that
they may wait the reason that was given
i think it was a report from sports
business daily was the pandemic has
potentially no the
the pandemic itself
doesn't make it impractical to play an
extra game they've already proven they
can play the whole season or close to it
we don't want to jinx them with three
weeks left it's not about the pandemic
causing you to not do it it's about the
pandemic making you want to do it more
to make back your money
it's always about money mike right i
mean that's the bottom line is how much
money did they lose that's what we don't
know and how much money can they make
back by adding that extra game and this
was not something that was required
under the the cba but it was allowed and
the nfl can choose to do it whatever
year they want to do it that the union
now doesn't have to approve this they've
agreed to it within the cba so the nfl
can decide when they're going to do this
and it makes perfect sense that they're
waiting there's no reason today to vote
yes on this and say we're adding that
extra game time is on their side and
they'll use this time to figure out a
bunch of things going into 2021
and one thing that we do know now and we
reported this earlier because the
commissioner hinted at the reality
didn't hint at it he said they agreed on
a formula for the schedule when they go
to 17 games here's what it will be and
this very quickly becomes complicated
i'll try to make it as simple as
possible already every team
in
any nfl division plays all four teams
from another division every year and it
rotates the cowboys for example is i see
the roger staubach jersey in the
background they and the other three
teams of the nfc east play all four
teams from an afc division this year
it's all four teams of the afc north the
cowboys play all four washington plays
all four the eagles play off for the
giants playoff four that will continue
the 17th game will be an extra inner
conference game from one of the other
three divisions and that will also
rotate where first place from the nfc
east plays first place from for example
the afc south second place plays second
place third place plays third place
fourth place
plays fourth place and as it works out
without getting too deep into the weeds
here currently the 16 game formula
sharing has only two games that really
hinge on where you finished the prior
year two games per year it's against two
other teams in the conference based on
where they finish first place plays the
other two first place teams and then for
the third division you play all four of
them that's how it rotates in the
conference those two games now get
expanded to three which is good for the
bad teams because for example
if you're
uh
let's say
the the cowboys which will be the worst
team in the nfc east let's say next year
the the division where you do one plays
one two plays two etc is the afc south
the cowboys get the jaguars
and the team that wins the division is
going to get the titans or the colts so
that's one more game
where some strength of schedule is built
in so i like that aspect of it and it is
going to give us
every year
multiple games where division champions
are playing division champions which can
be put in prime time which should be
good games which could be super bowl
rematches uh so i think i think i like
what they're doing with this 17th game
i love it mike and you know you have
certain teams that only get to see each
other once every four years and and
that's not enough i mean
this year the cowboy steelers game was
was not what the cowboy steelers game
has been but those two teams have played
some great regular season games and you
want to see that more often and there's
a bunch of those games you want to see
more often between nfc an nfc team and
an afc team and we don't get to see that
you know tom brady uh playing against
aaron rodgers hasn't happened very much
because tom brady spent most of his
career in the afc so all those things
are great to see and and i want to see
more of that i want to see more of nfc
teams against afc teams so i absolutely
love that that's what they decided to do
with this
i know peter king and others have been a
proponent of something that is more set
so it's every year eagle steelers every
year or eagles cowboys every year where
you've got
a rival from the other conference that
you're guaranteed to play every year
well what do you do in the year where
you're playing all four teams from that
team's division do you play them twice i
think it gets impractical this will be
more of an automatic formula
and and there's no guarantee for example
that the cowboys and steelers will will
face each other other than once every
four years but there is a chance now a
one in four chance we'll see them twice
every four years with a guaranteed
minimum of once every four years so i
like it it's more football and it's
going to be good teams against good
teams and those good games will likely
be standalone that we can enjoy and
hopefully they'll be like the game that
we saw on monday night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports